everybody underestimates that kick in
the groin hey i'm comedian al Madrigal
and these are my five favorite internet
videos the first one is called cheeto
champ
a Chapel Hill teen is one bragging
rights in the snack world as the owner
of what could be the largest cheeto on
earth
I love local news I love local news
stories like this one fifteen-year-old
Nick Robinson is your average teenager
he's into computers music video games
and Cheetos big Cheetos I love the fact
that this kid is bidding for Cheetos on
eBay apparently this is an auction that
never took off nobody really noticed it
so I accidentally won this auction if
you don't think a big Cheetos a big deal
think again I love the correspondent not
too impressive wants to put it next to
Nick's big 5 I love the fact that the
dad is behind this kid's hobby which is
collecting abnormally large snack food
that is a big old heavy cheeto and I do
love his joke at the end that is super
cheesy he says he hasn't decided what to
do with the orange mound of goodness yet
but he says whatever he does it'll
probably be cheesy this next video is
called rappin for Jesus well I wrote
this song for the Christian youth I want
to teach kids the Christian truth if you
want to reach those kids on the street
then you gotta do a rap do a hip-hop
beat somebody made it for their pastor
who wanted to reach out to the youth and
the only way to do that is through rap
it's fantastic he's a life changer
miracle arranger born to the Virgin mom
in a manger there's an N bomb it's gonna
be bleeped out but wait for it my crew
is big and it keeps getting bigger
that's cuz Jesus Christ his men whoo
this next video is a little tiny girl
named Maya peacefully sleeping until her
favorite song comes on
[Music]
and you really got to go back to the
beginning just to watch how out she is
and then it kicks in you watch that over
and over again it's great all right this
is called hey Ron hey Billy very quick
this last one is one of my favorite
videos of all time
this is bas Rutten self-defense video
and been about it for many many years
MMA fighter in a bar showing you a
regular person how to protect themselves
oh by the way after that they give the
date of the day I love biggity biggity
bang look at what we found here looky
look what we got here
smack his face smack his face a little
violent it's a lot violent but give it a
chance
right away you say okay I'm sorry bang
bang bang no I'm not thank you very much
for watching I've been al Madrigal hope
you liked those videos
[Music]